mehrere dutzend soldatinnen und soldaten
sind seit heute morgen im einsatz und
fb2 schutzmasken an soziale
einrichtungen in ganz österreich aus zu
lieben und gestern am abend ist eine
anforderung eine assistenz anforderungen
des gesundheitsministeriums bei uns
eingetroffen
da geht es darum dass bis spätestens am
montag in etwa 52.000 fb2 masken an 243
sozialeinrichtungen in ganz österreich
geliefert werden sollen und die perfekte
logistische arbeit die das
österreichische bundesheer leistet hat
heute dann 90 700 bereits begonnen so
dass wir wahrscheinlich heute noch
fertig werden es gehört ganz großer dank
den soldatinnen soldaten und
zivilbediensteten meines ressorts die
ihre besondere logistische kompetenz
wieder einmal unter beweis stellen
herzlichen dank